>>I'm John Sweeney. I'm the Joseph Brown Whitehead professor of surgery,
and chairman of the Department of Surgery for the Emory University School of Medicine.
Muscle Insertion and chief Emory health care.
We became interested in this problem in about 2009- 2010,
and it was based on a landmark paper that was
published in New England Journal of Medicine in 2007.
In that paper the authors found that Medicare patients
discharged from the hospital we were readmitted an enormous number,
almost 20% of those patients.
And within 30 days after discharge the cost
to the health care system was in the billions of dollars.
And so, it was creating a significant amount of interest at the federal level.
And as part of the patient protection Affordable Care Act Section, 13:24,
which is the readmission Reduction Act was signed into law which
penalizes hospitals that have access readmission rates over what's expected.
And so, this has become a substantial problem and generated substantial focus for
hospitals around the country to reduce
their readmission rates and improve outcomes for their patients.
It's an interesting problem.
As we started looking at the readmission problem,
we realized that there were several factors at
play that needed to be considered not just the simple readmission.
The first was the decision to send the patient home.
One was the patient ready to be discharged.
And keeping in mind with that that the longer patient stays in the hospital,
the higher the costs associated with that.
And so, our doctors are incentivized to reduce costs
and move patients through the hospital care segment.
If they move too quickly, patients could potentially be readmitted.
And so, we felt that the tool that brought information to
bear that help providers make timely decisions,
that were more effective and reduce
readmission rates really could make a huge difference in
the outcomes for patients but also decrease costs for health care system.
I am a practicing general surgeon.
I do complex general surgery and so because my interest is in that area
and patients that undergo
complex general surgery can have readmission rates as high as 20%,
we initially focused on a large dataset of patients here at
Emory University Hospital that had previously undergone complex GI surgery.
And we looked at readmissions in those patients and with the help of
the economists working at Georgia State built a predictive model that
helped us with more likely
predicting one it was the appropriate time to send a patient home from the hospital.
We then took that tool into
the simulated setting and actually both using a computer simulation setting,
and also mock patient actors
in a simulation setting here in the Emory Center for experiential learning.
We actually showed that this tool does have benefit,
and we think that in the true clinical setting would lead to reduce readmissions,
decreased like this day,
and improve outcomes overall for our patients.
The big issue for us now is as we've put a considerable amount of work
into developing what we think is something that could
have some significant benefit at the bedside,
as how to be able to integrate an electronic record with
this decision support tool and really firers the mechanism for doing that.
It's the opportunity that's going to allow us to bring to bear what we've
spent a lot of time working on and what we
think is going to make a difference for patients.
And also, make the decision making process easier for provider.
The future of our tool I think is the next step,
is going to be a clinical trial with the tool and the clinical arena.
We've already shown the utility
both in the computer simulated setting as well as in a mock patient setting.
But in reality what needs to happen next is this tool needs to be
trialled in the clinical setting to demonstrate its utility.
The risks of readmission and the impacts of
a readmission as well as the impacts of a prolonged length of stay are significant.
And therefore, we think that this needs to be trialled in a
controlled setting before turn loose on the healthcare environment.